if you look at most substances so this
is most things right over here as we go
from a liquid state where things are
literally fluid the molecules are moving
past each other to a solid state where
things are rigid or more rigid you
typically have something getting more
dense so the liquid state would be less
dense less dense and the solid state
would be more dense would be more dense
let's think about what would happen if
water were like most things here so
imagine a body of water so imagine so
let's say that's the land right over
here this is a cross-section of a body
of I don't want to draw a brown water I
want to do blue water so this is a
cross-section of a body of water like
say we see in this picture here and
let's say it is very cold that the air
is extremely cold let's say it's below
the freezing temperature of water
well what would happen is the water up
here would freeze and this is actually
what what does happen water at the
surface would freeze but if this ice
were more dense the solid water were
more dense than the liquid water well
then the ice would sink the ice would
sink and collect at the bottom the ice
would collect at the bottom right over
here and then the water over here would
freeze again it would freeze again but
if that were more dense then it would
sink and collect at the bottom and you
keep going with this process on and on
and on and eventually the entire body of
water the entire lake the entire lake
would freeze solid would freeze it would
freeze solid now you could imagine this
wouldn't be that good for the animals
that are living in the water if you
imagine some fish in here
those fish would Jen freeze and most
living things there are a few simple
organisms that can survive being frozen
but most living things would just die
and so this would not be a good
environment for for animals to live in
or for even biology to take place but
what's neat about water it does not
follow this pattern when we're talking
about water when we're talking about
water when we go to the liquid state
when we go from
liquid water to solid ice to solid ice
we actually get we actually get less
dense so this right over here is less
dense this is why this is why ice floats
so this is more dense more dense and
this is less dense and to think about
why that is it all goes back to the
hydrogen bonding so we've seen in
previous videos so I'm going to do it
all in one color oxygen hydrogen
hydrogen and let's say this is the
liquid state that I'm drawing right over
here this is this is liquid water liquid
water so then you have oxygen you have
oxygen and hydrogen and hydrogen and you
have oxygen and hydrogen and hydrogen
we've already talked multiple times
about the fact that you have partial
negative charges at the side away from
the hydrogen's partial negative partial
negative because oxygen is so
electronegative and you have partial
positive charges on the hydrogen ends
partial positive charges at the
hydrogen's and these partial negatives
and partial positives attract each other
and this is called hydrogen bonding now
in a liquid state you have enough energy
a temperature is just really average
kinetic energy that these molecules are
able to bounce around and flow past each
other these hydrogen bonds get broken
and get reformed over and over again
these things flow past each other and
also they have enough energy to kind of
push even closer to each other than even
the hydrogen bonds would dictate
sometimes they go closer sometimes
they're further sometimes they're
pushing around but as we get as we get
cooler as we get cooler and we lose heat
then they don't have that kinetic energy
to kind of get closer and bump up
against each other and and and and move
right and flow right past each other and
they form a a lattice structure where it
will look more like this where it will
look like oxygen hydrogen hydrogen
oxygen hydrogen hydrogen oxygen hydrogen
hydrogen and so you actually have the
molecules being further apart from each
other because they don't have the
kinetic energy once again to keep
breaking and reforming these hydrogen
bonds and or even to kind of have the
kinetic energy to push up against each
other and
so you form this lattice structure you
can even have another oxygen and I'm
obviously drawing it in two dimensions
but ice things in our in our universe
and our reality are three dimensions but
hopefully this this gives you this gives
you the big picture of it oxygen
hydrogen hydrogen and so you have these
hydrogen bonds well I wanted to do those
in white these hydrogen bonds and
remember these hydrogen bonds they're
just they're still is still the case
electrons are still moving around and so
you still have a partial positive charge
here and partial negative charge there
but there's not enough kinetic energy to
push them close to each other and flow
past each other and so you have ice
right over here you have solid water you
have ice over here being less dense and
this is what keeps ice floating this is
what keeps icebergs floating this is
what keeps Lakes like this from freezing
solid that's why the surface freezes but
you have water below and in fact that
ice on the top cut protects the water
below from you can imagine you know the
ice is it protects it from from getting
even further frozen and so you have
animals you have animals able to just
you have animals able to just hang out
hang out down here and go through the
winter and then everything will thaw
once you get to the spring and the
summer